i remember the first time it happened i
was coming down court all of a sudden i
hear
and i'm like are you trying to let me
know you're open
like
dude there's 20 000 people in the
building
[Music]
book on the drive the finish
and the foul goes into that little crab
dribble leads back
giving the end one
so when you watch devin booker play you
see the pure jump shot you see him being
able to take people off the dribble you
can see him in pick and roll action you
can see him making good passes you can
see him playing next to chris paul you
see him doing everything but not only
can he do everything he does it well and
he looks so smooth doing it i played
with a guy who
looked just as smooth as devin booker
doing it and his name was joe dumas
backs him mid post hands look over to
help behind the back leave inside from a
horn great pass he lays it up and in
oh what a shot
dumars slices in for the basket he's an
offensive weapon like never before joe
dumas take you off the dribble play pick
and roll he can post you up he couldn't
jump as high as devin but man they both
had pretty sweet jump shots and they
were killers joe in our era was known as
one of the best defensive players out on
the perimeter a lot of nights you know
he would have that tough matchup you
know whether it be jordan reggie miller
sydney moncrief joe would always have to
take that tough match up out on the
perimeter he was a great defender thomas
up ahead two more schumacher takes it
and hits it with the left hand isaiah
demars tie again behind the back to
isaiah sideline right to dumars the
rainbow goes joe dumas
playing with joe the thing that always
was crazy about joe and i was the
connection that we had out on the floor
i remember the first time it happened i
was coming down court all of a sudden i
heard
and i'm like are you trying to let me
know you're open
like
dude there's 20 000 people in the
building and from that point on every
time that he was open no matter what
arena we were playing in i had to train
my ear
to listen to
fast forward now we're here and i'm
working at nba tv in tnt and reggie
miller comes in out all these years that
i'm i've coached reggie miller with the
indiana pacers he said coach i finally
want to ask you this question what was
joe doing when i would be guarding him
and all he was saying
what did that mean i said reggie that
meant that he was open and i'm supposed
to throw him the basketball
umar stole it 12 foot jumper that's good
great play by joel drives around worthy
comes in deep throws it up and banks it
in left-handed dumar six out of nine
dribbles around worthy and deep stop
eight foot jumper that's good i don't
believe what i'm seeing he's just too
smooth in the 89 series against the
lakers they put james worthy on joe duma
now james don't laugh don't get mad
cause you know he cooked you even though
you cooked us too james worthy having
the guard joe dumars out on the
perimeter magic couldn't guard him
worthy couldn't guard him so we just
kept going to joe and joe got hot he was
hot throughout the whole series i guess
they found out like joe dumars was the
real deal hall of famer now joe newmars
dumars takes it baseline around jordan
turn around shot good right baseline
nifty move by joe dumars
well that was a sweet stroke that was a
beauty march oh what a shot double head
the book book
and booker makes him pay with an and one
so when you look at devin booker and you
look at his game you can really mirror
it to joe dumars and i'm sure chris paul
would echo what i'm saying right now
devin booker is the perfect partner for
chris paul like joe dumars was the
perfect partner for me
[Applause]
you